christian shottle mer les centristes de
janvry dans l'essonne et françois code
qu'il est essayiste et ex orateur de la
france insoumise
messieurs bonjour tous les deux françois
cocq première question la mobilisation
belz un petit peu certes mais continue
depuis cet été chaque saint denis
oui au delà de la question de la
mobilisation qui
noté est en baisse aujourd'hui depuis
depuis quelques semaines ce qui est
important c'est la pertinence du message
qui est qui et qui est posée on a bien
vu que le fondement de ceux de ce
mouvement c'est le choix qui a été fait
par le gouvernement durant l'été le 12
juillet lui même très exactement lors de
discours et de l'intervention du
président des présidents macron de la
coercition plutôt que de la conviction
et à partir de là mais les gens ont
commencé à s'agréger pour dire qu'il
n'acceptait pas la décision car telle
qu'elle était prise et qu'il y avait
peut-être une autre manière de faire
dans ce pays pour recréer du corner et
créer une capacité d'entraînement
collective pour que collectivement nous
prenions les bonnes mesures face à
l'épidémie ça c'était la situation
initiale et puis il ya de nouvelles
mesures vous l'avez noté qu' qui
viennent s ajouter à cela le fait que
mercredi le porte-parole du gouvernement
la sortie du conseil des ministres est
évoqué le fait que le pass à lithaire
pourrait être étendue au-delà de
l'élection présidentielle jusqu'à l'été
2002 est une manière de permanent qu'ils
aient à nouveau un état d'exception ça
avait été le cas avec l'état de
d'urgence et terroristes sous le
gouvernement hollande c'est le cas là
avec une forme d' état d urgence
sanitaire autrement dit le droit le
principe fondateur qui sont les nôtres
sont bafoués dans la forme et dans le
fond et cette manière de faire
aujourd'hui red bull se les gens et créé
peut-être une capacité d'agrégation qui
va au-delà de la simple question du pas
saint hubert qui pose une réelle
question démocrate démocratique je le
note d'autant plus que je voyais le
sondage qui vient de sortir et qui dit
que 14 % seulement des gens sont sûrs
d'aller voter à la prochaine élection
présidentielle nous devrions nous
interroger sur la manière et sur le sens
dans son mener des politiques publiques
dans ce pays christian totale j'allais
vous poser une question mais je vous ai
vu ce cou et à la tête est ce que vous
avez une réaction après ce que vous
venez d'entendre de la part de monsieur
coque
ces chiens là tout petit maire rural
beaucoup plus au ras des pâquerettes que
l'intervenant qui est d'intervenir et il
ya un discours qui est politique alors
qu'on est dans la gestion de la cité on
est on est quand même
avec une grande pudeur et les uns les
autres à être aussi définitive par
rapport à une situation il n'y aurait de
tous depuis toujours et on découvre on
est avec une canne blanche mme
obsessionnel local terre que moi depuis
deux ans je sers la crise au jour le
jour porte à porte avec des vrais gens
juba théorie mais que c'est vrai que je
suis toujours impressionné quand il ya
des grandes théories politiques sur un
un dossier qui me tiennent plus que
complexe qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que c'est tout à
fait étonnant d'antan le gouvernement
dira on reporte jusqu'à et jusqu'à l'été
la possibilité seulement la possibilité
il pas sanitaires ils disent pas qu'ils
maintiennent grâce à lutter jusqu'à
l'été mais il ya certains qui vont
beaucoup plus vite en manoeuvre qui qui
voudraient faire penser que de toute
façon ça sera maintenue jusqu'à l'été
moi je suis évidemment pas convaincu et
il garde la possibilité et pourquoi
font-ils ça ils font ça passe
depuis cette crise qui sont le
gouvernement est terrorisée par les
actions judiciaires qu'il peut prendre
sur la figure pour la moindre décision
qu'il prend et d'ailleurs du coup on est
passé de décision de bon sens la
décision de 10 mètres ceinture et
bretelles il met le parapluie pour se
protéger contre tous les gens les
snipers qui sont prêts à les attaquer en
justice pour pour des décisions qui
seraient prises qui n'auraient pas été
les bonnes et on en voit déjà les effets
sur certaines déjà deux décisions du
cisr que c'est vrai que je crois qu'il
faut être très méfiant et surtout
collégialement solidaire sur sur
l'inconnu auxquels nous sommes
confrontés depuis deux ans alors bien
sûr
daksi mais les enfants comme on nous
propose la vava créer des réactions
épouvantable
de le père poule et de mère poule ce qui
est normal les propres enfants disent
moi je verse in re es pas
un gosse et ils sont choqués et on peut
on peut comprendre tout ça et je
j'alerte tous les gens très sérieux qui
parle sur les écrans de
l'instrumentalisation les situations qui
m'ont beaucoup plus grave que les petits
enjeux politiques des prochaines
échéances
françois cocq se passe sanitaires à ce
que ça veut dire que le gouvernement a
échoué ça en tout cas ce qu'on entend
qu'il n'a pas réussi à convaincre les
français finalement aller vers la
vaccination
at il seulement essayé le 12 juillet
quand monsieur macro est intervenu son
travail sa responsabilité aux et
d'essayer de nous entraîner
collectivement vers la vaccination qui
est l'un des outils à notre disposition
faire face à l'épidémie et ce jour là il
a décidé de vouer plutôt du bâton ce
qu'il a fait c'est qu'il nous a mis le
couteau sous la gorge en nuisant
vaccinez vous ou sinon vous n'aurez
droit finalement a plus rien et vous
deviendrez des citoyens de seconde zone
ça a été ça le discours et c'est ça la
manière dont les choses sont conduites
et de ce point de vue le gouvernement et
le président macro ont une attitude
extrêmement autocentré je le dis à
monsieur le maire le gouvernement aurait
pu faire un autre choix que de se donner
la possibilité de prolonger l'état
d'urgence sanitaire jusqu'à l'été des 22
il aurait pu avoir une politique de
santé publique or celle ci est à l'arrêt
depuis des mois et des années ce n'est
pas moins monsieur le maire c'est le
ministère de la santé de lui-même le
ministère de la santé qui est coupable
aujourd'hui celui là a annoncé cette
semaine cette semaine au moment même où
il annonçait sa prolongation de l'état
d'urgence une étude l'a rendu publique
une étude qui annonce qu'il a eu cinq
mille 700 lits supprimés à l'hôpital
public en france en 2020 vous entendez
donc plutôt que d'agir sur les moyens
concrets qui serait à sa disposition le
gouvernement se préoccupe de son petit à
venir de la manière dont il va ce
pouvoir se protéger des responsabilités
qui devraient qu'il devrait porter et le
problème du politique aujourd'hui est à
la fois d'un côté cette impuissance mais
aussi cette irresponsabilité à sion
qu'il est en train de construire et
qu'il fait qu'il ne voudrait plus avoir
à rendre des comptes et qui lui servait
personne ne voudrait même plus avoir à
rendre des comptes dans les urnes
monsieur le maire je voulais faire
répondre très rapidement parce qu'on est
pressé par le temps
sincèrement je ne fais pas la politique
sur un élu local ridicule ce que de ses
habitants là on est sur un discours que
je comprends bien dans le climat sont
dans lequel on est c'est vrai que on
sait tous que
si le passé ni terre n'avait pas été une
obligation et un certain nombre de gens
qui ne lui aurait pas été c'est clair et
les convaincre et les convaincre de le
faire alors maintenant est-ce que ce
vaccin avant a fait avancer les choses
et qu'on s'en sort mieux franchement les
chiffres semblent le dire
mais ce qui me ce qui met ce qui me gêne
c'est qu'on instrumentalise d'une
situation franchement quand on est dans
la tempête et qu'elle se sait un peu
qu'on tapait sur les pompes ces jeux
m'interpelle sur l'intérêt public et
encore une fois moi je suis au jour le
jour avec des vrais gens je suis pas
juge pas dans la théorie il ya il ya
aujourd'hui je crois 1500 personnes qui
sont en réanimation n'en avait 5000 n'y
a pas si longtemps je dis que quelque
part les choses avancent ou alors j'y
comprends rien alors il y ait beaucoup
de vide fermé mais je pense que c'est
une politique qui n'a qui ne date pas
d'hier était triste triste mais mettre
la politique de santé ce credo du coc
vide à mon avis et c'est encore une fois
joué un mauvais jeu c'est pas c'est pas
le problème et les gens qui défilent
dans la rue aujourd'hui ces gens qui ont
peur c'est des gens qui ont l'impression
qu'ils sont qui sont cernés et quand
même condamnons les uns les autres avec
un peu de sérieux doutes et et théories
complotistes qui sont franchement
totalement ahurissante
messieurs merci à tous les deux d'avoir
été en direct sur arte france avec nous
donc à christian shot le maire les
centristes de janvry dans l'essonne et
puis à françois cocq essayiste ex
orateur de la france insoumise merci à
vous tous